TIM WILDE: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Thanks for coming to today's
Authors at Google session.
I'm Tim Wilde, for those
of you who don't know me.
Today we're joined
by Joyce Chaplin,
Ph.D. She's an award winning
author and the James Duncan
Phillips professor of early
American history at Harvard
University.
Joyce will be talking to us
about her most recent book,
which most of you have copies
of, "Round About the Earth--
Circumnavigation from Magellan
to Orbit," in which she
explores the full
history around the globe
travel over the course
of almost 500 years.
So without further ado,
thanks for speaking with us,
Joyce, and here you go.
Welcome.
JOYCE CHAPLIN: Thank you.
Thanks so much.
It's really a great
pleasure to be here
and to be speaking
about this book
that I did that came
out a couple years ago
and I kind of miss as a project.
It was really, really,
really fun to work on,
so I'm always delighted
to talk about it.
And I'm going to begin
with an invitation,
a kind of imaginative exercise.
Please imagine that
for some odd reason,
you have to ordered your
very own around the world
kit, which comes
in several pieces
and requires special delivery.
It takes the form of a
theater in which you're
going to stage your own
around the world voyage.
You're going to manage that.
The kit will require
special delivery
because the theater
itself, which is round,
is about 8.25 meters
across-- in circumference,
I mean-- so just under
nine feet across.
You can just about enter it.
Not very big, but surprisingly,
the other components
turn out to be even
smaller, as you
discover when you
enter the theater.
On the door of the theater,
you'll find an envelope.
The envelope has a map
and a magnifying glass.
The map of marks with
an x a particular spot
within the theater,
and you're going
to need the magnifying
glass to find
what is at that spot marked x.
It is a tiny ship, a ship
the size of a head of a pin.
Beside that ship, you'll
find a microscope,
and only with its
help will you discover
that what look like tiny bits
of dust on top of the ship
are tiny sailors,
like specks of dust.
They're tiny dolls
that represent
the men who keep
the ship on course.
Now, this kit that
you've ordered
has these kind of
bizarre dimensions
because correctly
proportioned to each other,
the theater is the
Earth, this ship
is the Victoria-- the first
ship to make a circumnavigation.
The tiny dolls are the
sailors, the angels that dance
on the head of this
particular pin.
Given the high mortality
rates during most
of the history of around
the world voyages,
sailors were indeed angels
in the making, about to die.
Their tininess and the
smallness of their ship
make a circumnavigation of the
comparatively enormous globe
seem impossible, and yet it
happened-- over and over,
hundreds of thousands of times,
and even more circumnavigations
are taking place
right now as I speak
on every level of the
Earth, both beneath the sea,
on the surface, and in orbit.
With those repeated embraces
of the globe from 1519 onward,
human beings have
established what
is now a nearly
500-year tradition
of going around the world.
It's the longest tradition
of a human activity done
on a planetary scale, 500
years of a planetary activity.
Around the world
travelers therefore
make a grand gesture as
big as the physical world
itself even though
they are individually
so small that the huge global
stage on which they make
those voyages makes
them hard to find.
I like to say that I found
the topic of circumnavigation
in the middle of
the Atlantic Ocean.
Seven years ago in
St. George's Bermuda,
I embarked on 140-foot sailing
ship, the Sea Education
Association's sailing school
vessel, the Corwith Cramer.
So off I went with
a group of students.
I was going to be at
sea for three weeks.
I was an instructor
and deck hand.
It's a very interesting
combination.
And it was a three week
stint that I would spend away
from telephone,
internet, everything.
It was actually kind of blissful
to be removed from all of that.
But I was in the
middle of a project.
My book before this
one was a project
on Benjamin Franklin
and science,
and this was going to require
me to read material in French.
So I decided when I was at
sea for these three weeks
being a deck hand,
occasionally teaching,
I would brush up my French.
I was going to bring
a novel in French.
Completely by chance,
I picked Jules Verne,
"Le Tour du monde en
quatre-vingts jours"--
"Around the World in 80 Days"--
first published as a newspaper
serial in 1872.
When I wasn't on wash
or being a deck hand,
I made my way pretty
slowly at first
through this French novel.
My French was good
enough, kind of
to my surprise, that I
actually enjoyed the book.
I really got into
the story, a lot
of the details of which
I had kind of forgotten.
As a historian, I
appreciated the period
detail of the novel,
the late Victorian era.
And I especially
appreciated the nature
of the bet, the wager that sends
a Verne's character, Phileas
Fogg, racing around the world.
At his London club, Fogg remarks
that scheduled travel services
could now put a person
around the world in 80 days.
His fellow club members
don't believe him,
so they say prove it,
and so off he goes.
That 80-day measure-- 80
days around the world--
was only conceivable by
the late 19th century.
In the age of sail,
going around the world
would have required
weeks-- I'm sorry months,
if not years-- so my
sailing vessel would
have lost Phileas Fogg.
80 days would have
been impossible.
It was the invention
of steam power,
but also the creation of
regimented European empires
around the globe plus commercial
travel services that together
made it just
possible by the 1870s
to go around the
world in 80 days.
I appreciated the period
detail of the novel.
The second thing that impressed
me about Verne's story
was how the material
developments that sped up
global travel required a
dramatically increased use
of natural resources.
When Fogg leaves
London on his voyage,
he takes his new
valet, Passepartout,
the comic character
of the novel.
The two men board a night
train, which has scarcely
departed London when
Passepartout lets out,
as Verne says, a
real cry of despair.
"In the rush, my
state of confusion,
I forgot to switch off the
gas lamp in my bedroom.
'Well, my dear fellow,'
Phileas Fogg replied coolly,
'you'll be paying the bill.'"
The gas lamp is the
novel's running joke.
You know it's burning
the whole time.
80 days of gas
burning in someone's
bedroom back in London.
True, it's only a small
part of the journey's cost,
but we present day
readers of Verne
quickly realize that
the joke is on us.
We are notoriously
the first generation
that has realized what the
planetary bill for centuries
of burning fossil
fuels is going to be.
And Verne himself recognized
this on some level.
He does not discuss
a carbon footprint
for this 80-day
journey, but it's
represented in the frontispiece,
the illustration, where
Passepartout and
Fogg are gazing up
the world that
they're going around.
Right, there they are
with various modes
of their transport represented--
elephant, sailing ship,
and so on.
But in the middle of that
globe, if you notice,
there's the gas lamp
burning, burning,
burning for all
of those 80 days.
Fossil fuel represented in the
very first page of the novel.
In Verne's era, coal
and other fossil fuels
were costly but essential
parts of modern progress.
Yet Fogg's
steam-powered exploits,
set at the height
European imperialism,
represent a face of the
past that truly is history,
meaning it's now over.
Airplanes have replaced the
coal-burning locomotives
and ships that hurdled
fog around the world.
The empires that protected some
people at the expense of others
have been replaced with
other political regimes.
It's now difficult to cross
the surface of the world in 80
days, though easy to fly around
it if you can afford the ticket
and if your government
gives you a passport.
So that is what
I learned at sea.
Once I was back
on land, I looked
for a history of around
the world travel.
I thought, there must be one.
There was none.
So I wrote one.
I decided that that was a
gap that I did absolutely
want to fill.
So here we are.
When I began the
book, I very quickly
decided that there
is no point in trying
to document all of the
round world voyages,
even all of the important ones.
There were far too many.
I didn't want to
write an encyclopedia.
That's not what the book is.
It records a number of firsts.
They're all there.
You can look it up
as a reference work,
if that's the way you
want to approach it.
But really, the part of the book
that I thought was important
was its argument.
I wanted to explain why
a circumnavigation is
distinctive.
Why does going around
the world matter
in the larger scheme of things?
It matters because it shows how
human beings have been thinking
themselves on a planetary
scale for a fairly long time,
for almost 500 years.
Circumnavigators have generated
nearly half a millennium's
worth of evidence of humanity's
direct tangible connection
to something that's
usually perceived
in the abstract,
the whole Earth.
This is really
significant that we
have this history of thinking
of ourselves in relation
to the planet very, very
tangibly for almost 500 years.
Of course, humans have
had a relationship
to the planet for as long
as they have existed.
But consciousness and
awareness of that connection
has been thought to
be only very recently,
from maybe the 19th
century onward.
Most people in the
more remote past
are not usually
thought of as having
any conception of themselves
on a planetary scale.
They were supposed
to be thinking small,
to be tucked into very
small parts of the globe
and to only kind of think
of themselves locally.
So it was allegedly
only by the 19th century
that mastery of the oceans and
penetration into continents
gave Europeans, Western
Europeans, the world's
first version of a
planetary consciousness,
augmented by developments
in science and geography.
It was only supposedly, again,
with the famous Apollo 8
photographs of 1968-- the
Apollo 8 photographs of Earth--
that humans first truly grasped
their place on the Earth
as a whole.
Today, of course, we're
hyperaware of our connection
to the planet given our ongoing
environmental crisis, most
of which can be attributed
to human actions
in generating matter that
overheats the atmosphere,
clogs land, air, and water.
We use our planetary
consciousness today
both to praise and to
criticize ourselves,
to emphasize our greater
scientific awareness
about the Earth, for
example, but also to stress
our unprecedented
transformation of it.
Plus, there's a sense of
globalization-- a key word
everyone talks about
now, globalization.
Surely, we must have
a greater awareness
of the planet given the
globalized culture in which we
live, the global connections
we know we now have with people
all over the world,
not least represented
in international business
education efforts such as are
represented very well
here in Cambridge.
But it may just be
the case, I think,
that no one has looked hard
enough to find a longer
history of planetary
consciousness.
If you don't look
for it earlier,
obviously you're not
going to find it.
Part of this has
to do with the fact
that globalization
has really hogged
all of the attention,
globalization.
Global is social.
It implies the human
to human connections
among people over
the entire globe.
In contrast,
planetary is physical.
It implies the
physical planet itself
and humans' awareness
of how they're
connected to that
physical place.
Far more studies, a
lot more journalism
has been devoted
to the former than
to the latter--
globalization again hogging
all the attention.
That's because human
to human interactions
are usually what historians
and journalists focus on.
Only recently for historians
have human relationships
with the non-human
parts of nature
been put into dialogue
with the human
to natural interactions that
are the other part of history.
We have only really begun
to read historical documents
thinking of the natural
world, the physical world,
as a context for understanding
human to human relations.
Circumnavigators' long
tradition, 500-year tradition,
of engagement with
the planet questions
our sense of
historical uniqueness.
Maybe we're not the
first generation
that has a planetary
consciousness.
Maybe it's not
something that only
emerged in the
late 19th century.
Instead, circumnavigators'
awareness of the planet
may teach us something
worth knowing
about why we think about the
Earth the way that we do.
I found that the
premodern circumnavigators
starting in 1500s onward
were by definition
not only thinking of themselves
in relation to the planet,
but doing something
in relation to it,
meaning they went around it.
Circumnavigation again is
the oldest human activity
done on a planetary
scale, and it's
16th century sailors
who did it first.
That's really kind
of astonishing.
With a technology we no longer
think is very efficient,
they did it.
I'm going to
proceed now to point
out three ways in which
circumnavigators described
themselves in terms of a full
planetary existence, traditions
that again, we still have.
First of all, the
circumnavigators' paradox.
This is the day that
is gained or lost
in going around the world,
crossing what we now
refer to as the
International Date Line, IDL.
It had been
theoretically known--
astronomers and geographers
had speculated yes, this
should happen-- if human
beings go around the world,
their calendar will
shift along with them.
But no one had experiences
until Magellan's surviving crew
made it back to Spain in
1522, having lost a day.
I like that kind
of random having
lost a day as they did so.
So ever since, the
temporal transition
has been a hallmark
of circumnavigation.
If you were to ever go around
the world over the poles,
hypertechnically,
that's referred
to as a transpolar
voyage because there
isn't the temporal shift.
It's not technically
a circumnavigation,
believe it or not.
It lacks this hallmark
characteristic of gain or loss
of a day.
All travelers change
their place on the globe.
They move through space.
Only circumnavigators change
the day on the calendar,
they change their place in time.
Second, circumnavigators
mark their voyages
on maps and globes as an entire,
again, planetary circuit.
The first example
occurred around 1530
with a small globe
probably made in Nuremberg
with the root of
Magellan's expedition
scored all the way around.
You see in the Atlantic
Ocean the voyage
going out, south,
through the Strait that
would bear Magellan's
name and then coming up
around Cape Horn in
Africa-- I'm sorry,
Cape of Good Hope in Africa.
This becomes, again,
another hallmark
of the circumnavigators'
passage--
the swoop around the
full globe, the desire
to mark on a map or
globe how you did it,
that this is the
circumnavigator's track,
was the first graphic
representation
of a human planetary
activity and becomes
very characteristic.
This is a beautiful map with
Magellan's track made in Venice
around 1540.
You see it more clearly there.
One of my favorite
examples, though,
has to be Francis Drake looted
his way around the world,
gaining a lot of silver
from the Spanish Empire.
So when he got back, he had this
beautiful double hemisphere map
made with his track
that you can see,
made in silver, the element
that he had returned with.
That's what he wanted his
circumnavigation marked as.
The temporal element--
the gain or loss
of a day-- the representation
of an entire planetary activity
through the
circumnavigator's tracks,
the third element was
how circumnavigators
took the physical globe as their
personal emblem or accessory.
The first to do so
was Sebastian Elcano,
the commander who
survived Magellan.
Magellan is the most famous man
never to go around the world.
He died in the
Philippines, and it
was Elcano who brought the
surviving ship to Victoria
back.
He was rewarded by
the King of Spain
with a coat of arms
that featured a globe.
So was Francis Drake,
so you see Drake
here with his coat of arms.
It has that globe with his
shift, the golden hind,
teetering on it at the top.
Later on, James Cook
would be awarded
a coat of arms that
also features a globe.
There would be a lot
of portraits also make
with circumnavigators holding
or leaning on a globe.
That is really interesting
because previously
to this, the only people
who would be pictured
with the whole world as
a kind of personal emblem
would be God, Christ,
and rulers, monarchs.
For ordinary
civilians or commoners
to gain this as an accessory was
quite extraordinary, and again,
marking a kind of understanding
of how going around the world
was so distinctive.
Many circumnavigators
beginning with Drake
had portraits made them in
which they hold globes, again,
something that only monarchs
or Christ had done so.
From the 16th century
onward, circumnavigators
claimed the privilege of
claiming the whole world
to mark their accomplishment.
As I discovered these elements
of circumnavigation, defined
very early from the
16th century onward
as characteristic way in
which people could have
a relationship with
the entire planet,
I defined around the world
travel as a geodrama,
using the Greek
for Earth, "Gaia,"
and for action, "drama."
Within the European
countries that
sponsored the first
circumnavigations,
there was an
established tradition
of considering the world
as a theater, teatro
mundi-- all the world's a stage.
This was an ancient Greek idea
updated in the Middle Ages
and Renaissance and exemplified
in Shakespeare's claim
that all the world's a stage.
Theatro mundi was a
metaphor, obviously,
but around the world travelers
made it into a reality
by presenting
themselves as actors
on a stage of
planetary dimensions.
Over time,
circumnavigations would
be presented as
dramatic entertainments,
first in print, then on
stage, and today on film.
A geodrama is different
from geography,
which studies depictions of the
Earth made by writing, graphos.
While geography engages
the human eye and the hand
and the mind, geodrama
requires all of the body,
everything-- all
of a human being
and its range of physical
experiences in relation
to Gaia, the Earth.
That whole body experience
of the whole Earth
is well documented in the
accounts of circumnavigations,
which describe what it
felt like-- from agonizing
to exhilarating, depending
on the period of time
when the circumnavigation
was done,
depending on the
person's experience.
In fact, most people do not and
have not gone around the world.
It's a minority experience.
But everyone knows something
about how it should be
and how it might feel.
Everyone has some idea
of the big statement
that a circumnavigation
makes through geodrama.
For that reason, published
first person accounts
were the primary sources
that I used for the book.
And frankly, the more famous
the account, the better
because that indicated
the extent to which there
was an audience for
that work and many more
people knew about by
reading or experiencing it.
Together, the accounts
of circumnavigation
constitute the longest
and most sustained way
in which people have been
able to consider themselves
as actors within
a geodrama, even
as the drama changed over time.
Here, let me go into the
basic stages or changes, which
can be expressed as 3
acts in the drama, three
phases in which humanity
comprehend their place on
and experience in the world.
In the first act, which lasted
from Magellan's departure
from Spain through to James
Cook's death in Hawaii,
so down to 1779, the sailors
who went around the world
did so in fear.
It was reasonable for
them to be fearful
given the dangers of
an around the world
voyage in the age of sail.
It was in this initial
phase-- the longest,
if you notice, in the
history of circumnavigation--
that death prevailed.
Humans might take on the
planet, but I think of it
as if the planet could
just shrug them off,
which the plant routinely did.
I will go into the confidence
and the doubt later,
but I want to just give
some more detail about how
the fear was actually a
very rational response.
The death rates on
early circumnavigations
were, in fact, appalling.
This is why I'm using PowerPoint
rather than Prezzie in order
to get all the data in.
I did not cherry pick
the worst experiences.
These are absolutely
representative.
Attrition rates for
these early expeditions
could reach into the
90th percentiles.
Mortality rates nearly in
the 60th and 70th percentiles
were considered quite good.
The expectation eventually was
that you could not possibly
expect a return with
all of your ships.
You would lose
some along the way.
If you brought back one
or two, that was great.
So as you can see,
the attrition was
built into the experience
of the expedition.
Having a fearful attitude about
taking on the entire planet
through a circumnavigation
was entirely rational.
Let me just give
some comparisons.
Mortality statistics
for naval battles
and for maritime disasters
were in fact lower than
for circumnavigation.
Three examples-- the
first European voyage
to India, only 50%
of the men lost.
The Spanish armada casualties
on the Spanish side, 66%.
And then the Titanic disaster
of the 20th century, 68%.
This is just to give a
sense that the dangers
of a circumnavigation
combine the dangers
of war and disaster.
That was the
proportion of mortality
that people would
have experienced.
As well, again it was
expected to lose ships,
giving some indication of the
extraordinary expense of trying
to put on a circumnavigation
for a nation state that
would send out
such an expedition.
Of the five ships that Magellan
commanded, only one returned.
Three famous expeditions
that followed--
I'll show this to you again--
lost all of their ships.
This meant that the
few survivors we know
came back to Europe, got
back on someone else's ship.
That was the before picture
or the early picture
of circumnavigation.
Let me move to the improvement
in the 18th century,
when through deliberate effort,
the mortality rates went down.
The idea now was not to lose
most of the men in ships,
but to keep them.
Rates of return for
circumnavigations
shot up into the 90th
and 80th percentiles,
reversing the earlier
pattern entirely.
Survival rates just in
the 60th percentiles
were now consider troubling
rather than amazingly good.
From the 1780s until the
1920s-- what Stearns called
the long 19th century
or the 19th century
extended on either end--
during this period of time,
travelers who made their
way around the world
did so with a
striking confidence
that they could
survive the process.
They and their
companions would make it.
This was because
Western societies
had generated technology
and political networks that
seemed to have
conquered the globe.
It was not only possible
to go around the world,
but it became a popular pastime.
There were costs, not
all of them hidden,
but they seem outweighed
by the glories and the ease
of making a swing
around the planet.
Over the end of the 18th century
and over the whole course
of the 19th century,
going around the world
was no longer an
achievement confined
to the ranks of
professional sailors,
but instead available to
a broader range of people.
Two examples-- the first
handicapped person,
James Holman-- who was
blind-- went around the world
in the 1820s.
The first woman, a
stowaway, had gone
around the world in the 1770s
and a handful followed her,
but the first woman
to do it alone
all by herself, in confidence
that she could do this,
managed to do that in the 1830s.
Ida Pfeiffer was
a Viennese widow
who decided that
she wanted to travel
for the rest of her life.
And she goes around the
world more than once.
New signs of the new safety,
obviously, that people
who were handicapped,
unprotected
by a considerable masculine
presence, for instance,
could now go around the world.
It became important, as
well, for individual nations
to send ships or delegations
around the world.
A lot of nations
did this as soon
as they felt like they
could possibly do it.
It was like joining
a global club.
Yes, we have mounted
a circumnavigation.
We did so in this year.
The United States first did a
circumnavigation in the 1780s,
shortly after the
American Revolution,
an important demonstration
of independence.
Russia does it around the
same time, China and Japan
by the 1870s.
so this is the
global map made by
the first Chinese
circumnavigator, who
goes around the
world in the 1870s.
Korea does a circumnavigation.
They send a diplomatic
embassy around the world
not long after this.
And so at the present day,
when nations still mark
the first time, for
instance, that they
are able to put a
satellite in orbit
or to send an astronaut to the
International Space Station,
it still is a kind of
important demonstration
of your national
prestige, that you
are part of the club
that has this kind
of planetary presence.
The around the world travelers,
who in the 19th century
were pioneers in
this democratization
of circumnavigation,
were assisted
by two important developments.
First, the spread
of European empires
over most of the
globe, which meant
that a great deal of
the world was made
accessible to travelers
from the global West,
meaning from Europe
and its offshoots,
including the United States.
The second factor was
the emergence and growth
of commercial travel
services, which
we continue to benefit
from, obviously.
That trend was very
well represented
in Jules Verne's novel
"Around the World in 80 Days,"
when indeed, it is commercial
travel services that
mostly send Fogg
around the world.
This was possible after the
opening of the Suez Canal,
for instance, and the completion
of the transcontinental
railroad across
the United States.
In the very same year that
Verne's novel appeared
as a book, 1873, the English
travel company Thomas Cook
and Son organized the
first around the world tour
and it becomes a very common
thing for travel services
to offer from that time onward.
If you can pay for
this kind of travel,
certain services would
be provided for you.
Many other agencies
throughout Europe
would imitate that grand global
package tour and shipping
companies began to sell
around the world tickets.
These were great.
These were often for a
stated period of time.
You could get off in Singapore,
stay there for awhile
if you had business or
wanted to see things,
and then you would
catch the ship
that would come around next.
Sometimes the ticket
would be available to you
for two years or so.
You can make your
way around the world
in leisure, or deciding to
stay in different locations,
simply catching a
ship to continue
as convenient to do so.
It was glamorous to
go around the world.
Deliberately, it was packaged
as a very glamorous thing
to do for your honeymoon,
for your wedding anniversary,
after graduating
college, et cetera.
Going around the world was
glamorous, pleasurable, even
joyful.
This is one of my
favorite illustrations
from the period--
a Jazz Age couple
dancing their way
around the world.
Over the 20th century
and now into the 21st,
however, the confidence
about the human ability
in spanning the globe
gave weight to doubt.
That's the last act of geodrama,
the one in which unfortunately
we still kind of live.
Technologically,
newer forms of travel,
especially airplanes and
rocket-propelled space
capsules, revive the
sense of extreme danger
that had faded during the
relatively safer 19th century.
Just one famous example.
Amelia Earhart was trying
to set a record flying
around the world
when she was lost
trying to make a very perilous
landing on tiny Howland Island
in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean.
So really aviation and
continuing into space travel
revived a sense of
the intense danger
that had faded in
the 19th century.
Equally, it's now clear
that it was imperialism
that had smoothed the way for
most earlier circumnavigators
under political and
social circumstances
that it would be impossible
and unwise to try to reinstate.
Above all, there's
a growing sense
that the planet is again
beginning to bite back.
Now that the environmental
costs of planetary domination
have begun to haunt us,
to fly around the world
takes a prodigious
amount of fossil fuel
to do that in a jet plane,
a private plane, whatever.
Going into orbit
requires even more.
When the NASA space
shuttle still operated,
it required over 1,000 gallons
of liquid fuel per second
to achieve liftoff.
This is not an
inconsiderable use
of what we know is a shrinking
supply of energy and one
that is damaging to the planet.
This has meant that the new
trend in circumnavigation
is to demonstrate
sustainable energy.
Many sailing ships
have done this so far,
and solar impulse, the
solar powered airplane,
wants to make an entirely
solar powered circumnavigation,
indicating that entire
circuit of the planet
remains an important measure
or metric for how you measure
anything, including
sustainable energy.
That is the most
recent development
in circumnavigation.
I think today, we live
with all three legacies
of around the world travel.
We have a reemerging fear
that the planet could simply
shrug us off.
We still have, however,
continuing confidence
that we might be able
to generate technologies
and political alliances
to dominate the planet,
yet we doubt that it's
always wise to do so.
It's especially apparent at
this point in our history
that the characteristic
confidence of the 19th century,
especially the
late 19th century,
has been the shortest of
historical experiences
and perhaps the most
atypical, yet obviously
the most difficult
to relinquish.
We don't want to give that up.
Our current doubts seem
to be taking us back
to the fears of the
early modern period,
a circular return that matches
the swings around the planet
that themselves went through
the three acts of geodrama.
I want to stress, however,
that there were always
more hopeful elements to this
story, and those bright moments
matter, too, and
they make it clear
that the human past is
complicated and contradictory
as its present, whether seen
on a small scale or large, even
the largest of all.
In tracing this history
of planetary consciousness
as expressed through the history
of around the world travel,
I want to end by
pointing out that
individual circumnavigators
are themselves aware
of the history
and the traditions
that they are reenacting.
That has really continued
to the present day.
Circumnavigators from very early
on read each other's accounts
and commented on each
other's experiences
and saw themselves as extending
a process from the past
into the future.
They read each other's accounts
as models for their own voyages
and narratives.
I'll just give one
genealogy of this.
Sir Francis Drake
read the account
of Magellan's expedition.
William Dampir, a famous pirate
circumnavigator, read Drake.
George Anson read Dampir.
Louis Antoine
Bougainville read Anson.
A Russian circumnavigator
Krusenstern read Bougainville,
and then Charles
Darwin, who sails
around the world in the 1830s,
read Krusenstern, and so on,
even in the present day when
around the world sailors still
all pretty much routinely read
Joshua Slocum, the first person
to sail around the world alone.
He's kind of canonical reading.
You cannot be an around the
world sailor without reading
Slocum, who himself read Darwin,
so the genealogy continues.
Even people who would go around
the world by different means--
by bicycling, motorcycling,
walking, et cetera--
would refer back to the
longer maritime tradition
on which they thought
they were building.
We see this sense of
history, for example,
in the naming of spacecraft.
When NASA sent an unmanned
expedition to orbit Venus,
it was called Magellan.
They chose very well
by saying that this
would be a famous
circumnavigator,
the first
circumnavigation of Venus,
so why not call it Magellan?
It was also well named
because the device did not
make it back.
It resembled Magellan in
that way, like its namesake.
It was programmed to
descend into Venus'
spacecraft-meltingly-hot
atmosphere.
At some point, it stopped
transmitting data.
It was, unlike
Magellan, timed to die
at a very certain moment.
This naming pattern
was also true
of several of the space
shuttles which took astronauts
to orbit on the
International Space Station.
Several were named for famous
circumnavigating vessels,
including the Columbia, named
for the first US vessel,
to make a circumnavigation.
The history of our
planetary consciousness
is right there in these
extended traditions
of encompassing the entire
planet, which go back
to the start of
the 16th century.
It's a way in which we
are early modern even
as we think we are
very, very modern.
We are planetary because
we participate in and are
aware of traditions that go
back for half a millennium.
Thank you.
I'm very happy to take
questions if anyone
has anything they would
like to ask about.
AUDIENCE: I was especially
interested by the [INAUDIBLE]
re-used for individuals
rather than just the monarchs
or Christ.
This notion of
circumnavigation, it
must be connected
also to the idea
of getting to the
ends of the Earth
in various directions, the
edges of the known Earth.
We think of Marco Polo,
but as far as I know,
no one even in the 15th
century was thinking,
can I get from the
easternmost part of China
to the southernmost
part of Africa
or something like
this over land, even.
Is that because land
travel was so much
more difficult than sea travel?
Marco Polo was there
in the 12th century.
JOYCE CHAPLIN: Land
travel was much slower.
Everyone recognized that
maritime travel was-- doesn't
seem fast to us, but
it was much faster
than trying to go
continentally over land, which
is why a lot of
intercontinental exploration
was not done until
the 19th century.
It was, in fact, harder to do.
Yeah.
People did have a
sense that going
across a large extent of the
Earth, perhaps by sailing ship,
would be a prodigious
feat, even possible.
Commentary obviously on
Columbus and on De Gama
for crossing oceans.
Going around the
entire world, however,
was more than the
sum of its parts,
and I think recognized
as such at the time.
It had not been Magellan's
original intention.
He was just going to sneak
up to the spice islands
through the back door,
as it were, and then
go back the same way.
It's only after he dies, after
the survivors are in Indonesia,
that they realize they've
gone around most of the world.
Going back would be crazy.
They do an unintended
circumnavigation,
thus proving it was
possible, but again,
coming back with a tiny
percentage of crew.
One ship was a big
warning that not what you
want to do every day,
so seen qualitatively
as being quite different from
other kinds of long distance
travel, combining all of the
dangers of longer distance.
AUDIENCE: But even so,
for long distance travel,
there were pre-existing
trade routes--
we're talking about commercial
travel in the 19th century--
there were trade networks
back into ancient times,
going all the way to China.
I don't know how far into
Africa the trade networks were
continuous, but certainly
into Ethiopia and further.
But the idea that
an individual would
make trips to go to
the ends of the Earth
doesn't seem to be
an idea, or does it?
JOYCE CHAPLIN:
Well, I guess it's
an idea glimmering into
focus after expeditions
like Columbus and De Gama.
But again, there did seem to
be something qualitatively
different about doing the entire
globe as a trading venture.
And indeed, the thing
about Magellan's survivors
when they get back is
everyone loses money on that.
It was not lucrative.
The King of Spain gets whatever
advantage there might be
and no one else
does, even anywhere
near what they thought they
would get out of that voyage.
It was a real
question for a while
about why you would
want to do another one,
and indeed, given the
attrition rates, not attractive
necessarily to sign on for that.
Given the cost, a good sailing
ship was a real investment,
and to lose four or
five of them was not
something you would
want to do lightly.
So it remains a
real question, why?
What kind of training
voyage, for instance,
would benefit from a whole
circuit of the globe.
It remains kind of
problematic of a voyage
to do through at least the
early part of the 18th century,
though people continued to try.
Often, though, they
are unintended.
Somebody gets further than
they thought they were going to
and they just continue rather
than go around the other way.
AUDIENCE: What specifically
made it less lethal?
What was the big change?
I assume most people got
sick or starved, so what,
did they just start
bringing more food?
JOYCE CHAPLIN: Yeah, they
don't know about the citrus.
Scurvy was a big,
big, big killer.
And again, there's
a cumulative effect.
Crossing one ocean
was bad enough.
But your reward as a
circumnavigator was there
would be another one.
People just could not
bring enough food.
There's a political
problem as well,
that for a lot of the globe,
it was dangerous to make land
and to get food.
You were not welcome there.
So the provisioning was a kind
of physical problem of getting
enough on a ship, but
then reprovisioning
is a social and
political problem,
and that would not go away until
the empires of the 19th century
would say no, sailing ships
from particular nations
have the right to stop there.
That would help a lot.
Interestingly, sailors referred
to scurvy as earthsicknesses,
meaning that they
were sick for land.
It's like being homesick.
They were convinced that
to make land itself,
to breathe the air, just to be
on the land would restore them.
Because if it was a malady
that existed at sea,
then being on land
should probably cure it.
So there are accounts of sailors
being buried in the earth.
That would be even
better, right,
because they were in
their little earth vats
soaking up whatever
gave them strength.
Again, you've got to be able
to make land to do that,
and politically,
that was a problem
until late 18th,
early 19th century.
The rising survival
rates, however,
during the 18th
century were probably
due to more careful
provisioning.
There's an account of one of
those ships where the ship is
so tightly packed
with provisions
that they joke about having
to eat their way through.
That would help, certainly.
The work regimen was
often altered, as well,
so men would get
more sleep and rest.
Scurvy is one of those
debilitating diseases
where if you begin to have it,
any other stress on the body
is going to accelerate it.
Probably, the modified work
schedule helped, as well.
But they didn't pack
a lot of lemons.
The citrus cure, not
something that they
realized at that point.
AUDIENCE: How would
they pack lemon?
JOYCE CHAPLIN: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: I thought that
the big cure for scurvy
was fermented, like sauerkraut.
JOYCE CHAPLIN: Sauerkraut, yes.
It's so interesting.
It's so interesting-- NASA
compares space sickness--
the bad effects on
the body by not having
an Earth level of
gravity-- to scurvy.
NASA has said that they need
something like sauerkraut.
Sauerkraut didn't cure
anybody of scurvy.
There is no magic bullet
in this scenario, actually.
It did seem that it was
simply having more food,
whether had Vitamin
C in it or not,
which people didn't understand
until the 20th century,
and having a
modified work regimen
that helped to a certain extent.
Now even people like
James Cook think
that the land cure
works, that earthsickness
is the best way of
describing scurvy.
He would order his men, whenever
they made land, go for walk,
pick greens, and eat them.
That probably helped, too.
Not for the reasons he
thought, but that probably
would have assisted.
If they can make land
frequently enough to do that,
that would help.
Yeah, scurvy is a bad disease.
Must be sad.
Sorry, you had another question.
AUDIENCE: I did, actually.
I was curious to the gas light.
I haven't read "Around
the World in 80 Days."
I should go back to it.
But the gas light, one of the
interesting about gas light,
is that it stays on.
Like a candle.
Is that used as a metaphor
that candles burn down and gas
lights don't?
JOYCE CHAPLIN: It doesn't
mention it explicitly,
but obviously, everyone
reading the novel in 1872
would have understood that.
Why Phileas Fogg didn't a friend
or neighbor or housekeeper
to turn the darn thing off--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, could
have texted him.
JOYCE CHAPLIN: Telegraph,
it was called at the time.
But it's a great running
joke-- the cost, pennies
and pennies and pennies.
And poor Passepartout
is calculating them.
What is he paying me,
and will that cover it?
There's a great illustration
of the very end where
he's slumped in a chair reading
the bill, which sort of scrolls
down all over the floor.
They never give an estimate
of how much Fogg has spent,
though clearly by the
end it's catastrophic.
He's just throwing
money at people
who can take him
on the next leg.
The gas lamp is a calculation
of how an ordinary person would
think of that.
It's a kind of brilliant
stroke, I think,
if he would have that
imaginative touch
to keep a tally.
I recommend the novel.
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]